welcome back this is the Ben Shapiro
show we're taking your calls at eight
five five to thirty six thirty to twenty
eight that's eight five five two three
six thirty to twenty eight hey Jeremy
you're on the bench bureau she'll go for
it Jeremy
I've been quick question for you I
wonder if you could I think that Posse
Comitatus Act is a little bit murky for
people and I would like for you to maybe
explain how if Trump were to try to
enforce a national lockdown order how
that would come into effect if federal
trees were deployed could you explain
that a little bit so Congress has to
explicitly authorize the US military to
enforce US domestic laws and the Posse
Comitatus Act makes clear that the
president can't unilaterally just say
okay army I want you to go enforce a
national lockdown that can't happen in
the absence of congressional approval
for such action now what the government
can do is obviously mobilize in support
of civilian agencies like FEMA and
typically what you have is governor's
making a request for that sort of stuff
also the National Guard and Coast Guard
those can be activated but only if asked
by a state governor the Stafford Act the
national emergencies act usually the
president will activate these things and
he'll say okay basically these are ready
for governor's to come request things
and then the governor's request things
and then the US government can get
involved but it does require the states
to basically be okay with it and so the
idea that Trump can just declare our
broad national lockdown he's got pretty
broad authority but he can't just use
the US military to enforce a broad
national lockdown he can sort of request
one and I guess that that would be what
people are asking for but that's about
it
so one more question then if if he did
then what are the steps required and
what would it what would it look like so
let's say that Trump said I'm now
issuing a broad mandatory national
lockdown well if there was a state like
Texas and they said we're not going to
abide by your national lockdown would be
very difficult in the absence of a like
there's no authority in the president in
the absence of congressional action for
the army to go enforce that lockdown it
just can't happen it's not something
that is allowed constitutionally
speaking no he could theoretically go to
Congress and say I need an act that will
force Texas to go along with this and
they'll give me the authorization to use
the the
in order to enforce this law but I think
it's pretty unlikely that most states
would go along that or most Congress
people would go along with that it's a
radical expansion of presidential power
that is never before been considered
under the Constitution in the absence of
outright declarations of war by states
against the federal government which is
what happened during the Civil War okay
well thank you Ben I appreciate clear
that up for me yeah you bet don't don't
don't worry about president Trump
authorizing the National military to
come in and you know sit on your street
you'd have to have your governor
actually approve something in that order
I'm worried more about your governor
than the president is I guess what the
point that I am making okay David in
Ohio you're on the bench P oh sure go
for it David my questions is going okay
how are you I'm great I'm great actually
my question is pretty simple for you the
fact is with Trump having sent out
millions of dollars to the small
businesses they pretty much have gotten
their money right away and unemployment
is as you know overwhelmed severely
severely overwhelmed we're three weeks
behind actually in my wife and I have
not been paid yet they have not sent out
stimulus do you think that it's wrong
not to put the people first well the
problem is the mechanism for the
distribution of the cash David and that
this is again it actually comes down to
one of the major failings of public
sector versus private sector so the the
unemployment systems have been
understaffed under man and overwhelmed
by the fact that you now have literally
tens of millions of people who are now
filing for unemployment and then waiting
for their checks because the Small
Business Administration lends through
banks and banks are deliberately staffed
to deal with these sorts of loans
they've been able to really ramp up
their facility quite quickly private
production it turns out is quite good at
this and public sector is is really not
particularly good at this especially
because there's no incentive to do it
extraordinarily well other than you know
a sense of community so it would I
prefer that all the checks went out like
day one absolutely right then we're all
on the same page there nobody wants the
Trump doesn't want it the states don't
want it the unemployment offices don't
want it like nobody is sitting there
going you know it'd be great is if we
could hold up somebody's unemployment
check for another two months and
nobody's interested in doing that the
question is what is the facility and
flexibility for these offices to
actually get those checks out this is
for unemployment has been hit with
10-minute there's also a difference in
numbers here right which is that when 10
million people file for unemployment
simultaneously that is radically going
to overwhelm the system in a way that
even tens of thousands of businesses
filing with their banks for for loan
extensions is not going to operate right
the numbers are just too dissimilar and
the and the private industry side of it
is indeed more efficient there was
worried about by the way that the loans
weren't going to go out to those
companies fast enough even the first
couple days that the Small Business
Administration loan program was launched
so it's not unique to the public sector
it's just a lot worse I'm just everyone
frustrated everybody has a right to be
frustrated the government forcibly shut
down the entire economy and now you're
waiting be backfilled and like how long
is it gonna last nobody is saying the
data is not out there the experts are
not providing any road plan for getting
out of this they're not giving us any
metric where they say ok when once we
get to this number of deaths per day or
this number of infections per day then
such-and-such group can go back to work
like there's no plan nobody has
articulated anything and in the absence
of a plan and in the absence of money
things are gonna get ugly real fast they
better get those checks out
damn straight like right now yesterday a
really apreciate call hang in there dude
the checks are coming but we got to get
this country back up and running sooner
rather than later already more
coronavirus updates coming to you ASAP
plus we're gonna be talking with senator
rick scott from florida in the next hour
all about what exactly the federal
government should do to reopen this
thing what are the standards that should
be used when we talk about how to reopen
all of this all the latest from New York
because the information it continues to
flow forth will have all of your updates
on a moment-to-moment basis you're
listening to the Ben Shapiro show